[Music]
the Brown family holidays look a lot
different now that Sister Wives star
Cody Brown is down to just one wife
you've got to be able to talk about it
earlier this month Janelle confirms that
she and Cody are separated after almost
30 years of marriage Janelle has made it
pretty clear to me that she's
enjoying her life without me
I think if we both really sat down we'd
look at each other and say really we've
been separated for several months it's
easy to start pointing the other ugly
finger to blame
and so no I don't just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around and Mary Cody's first
wife called out the polygamist in the
one-on-one special and revealed they've
also officially split he's like like
we're not married we're not acting as
married and I said to him then if that's
where we are don't you think that we
should address that publicly and he said
no I don't want to address it
I don't want to address it I don't want
that to be out there publicly we've been
like literally separated for I would say
four or five years so we're we're
amiable as for Christine she announced
her split from Cody in November 2021 and
their messy breakup played out on this
past season of the TLC reality series
watching the episodes is hard but living
my life every day day to day I would say
it's so much better I like my life so
much better now so when it came time to
celebrate the holidays The Divided
family spent time apart from Cody who is
still with his Legal Wife Robin and each
other Janelle kept things bright and
merry with her and Cody's daughters
Madison and Savannah posing for this
family snap in Madison's North Carolina
home which she shares with her husband
Caleb and their kiddos Alex and Evie and
Christine who's still close with Janelle
swooped into the comments writing oh so
cute
I'm super close with Chanel but I just
consider telling my sister if she just
always will be Janelle also shared this
clip of her grandson Axel in his
Christmas play as the drummer boy
[Applause]
as for Christine she spent the holidays
playing games with her and Cody's
youngest daughter truly and Christine
and Cody's son Peyton he chose to hang
out with Janelle and Cody's Sons
Garrison and Gabriel who are currently
estranged from their father sharing
these snaps alongside the caption gotta
love the holidays with the fam I've just
been able to hang out with families more
often than ever before Mary opted for
some good old-fashioned girl time with
her bestie Jen Sullivan in Utah doing
their weekly insta live wearing matching
Christmas sweaters
as for Cody and Robin who have mostly
kept a low profile on social media in
recent years they kept their holiday
plans quiet but the two will be open
books for the upcoming Parts two and
three of the Sister Wives one-on-one
special set to air in January do you
think if Christine didn't object that
Mary and Cody would have gotten back
together uh yeah because when Cody says
and thinks that type of stuff it usually
happens
that's a lie that's not me I would never
do that
[Music]